[Music]
have you ever
done a dating app no you guys are all
nine year old i don't know why i asked
that
well isn't it a weird thing you swipe
left
you swipe right well what if you would
do it
in real life jubilee has put that to the
test
30 versus one dating app in real life
that's crazy she looks like she's about
to charge and punch the [ __ ] out of him
jesus christ all right let's watch this
30 damn he's got good odds
and shield to swipe through okay all
right great
okay so left is no right is yes
okay i used a couple
everything from tinder coffee meets
bagel
bumble i don't think it's weird to meet
someone online i think it's more you
just need to go into it
i met someone online and i think it's
weird
no i never used the abs what the [ __ ] is
that and with the possibility of meeting
someone cool
bring in the girls all right i guess we
can play along as well and and say who
we
would swipe left or right on this should
be fun
oh wow they're all online wow it do be
like that huh
wait it'd be so funny if he says no to
the first one
because they've been staring at each
other for a while setting this [ __ ]
shot up and i'm like
no i mean obviously
i no him
this is so awkward right we're like
totally sad next
you're done now
[Music]
now
no what the [ __ ] is that stare
you better pick me young man
or else there will be
that is consequences awkward what
oh it's beautiful
pick me pick me pick me
damn it
[Laughter]
oh she should play poker she i don't
know what the went through her brain
no yet they look the same
they both look the same what the [ __ ]
they look identical why would you what
made you chip
oh their faces oh
look at their little faces oh
no one will ever love you face i don't
know why i love this so much
[Music]
it's only fun watching them getting
rejected
all right yeah you try
they try to hide it that's the thing i
see it
i see the face it's very subtle it's
very subtle but it's there the look of
[Music]
disappointment
you feel pain why am i laughing i'm
sorry
jesus christ how many are left no
no no no oh god there's so many more
[Music]
again they look the same
so he picked no one her but yes on her
what's the difference what made you p
are you just
whiffling your arms around
listen i'm married i'm not gonna judge
the girls
and that i and yeah that's it that's the
end of that line
i just don't understand what he's
thinking
guess he likes asian looking girls
what was that with the last one
a little power play there at the end
he's like yeah you get to go
sociopath the [ __ ] is wrong with you
playing playing
with people with emotions like that
clearly
disgusting they're unbelievable 16
potential matches
so what's that a little intimidating i'm
not gonna lie like i'm gonna get like
the [ __ ] out of me like
what's next if you would swipe
left which means no here
please leave oh
oh my god somebody left yes
oh that is pretty crushing man
that's gonna feel terrible what a beta
cringe dude
if i did this everyone everyone
no more i don't care what dating coaches
say
about me all right everyone would swipe
left or right i don't know the
difference
all right well you got six my dude
angela has
30 minutes emily
hey i'm the other blonde girl that you
picked nice to meet you ancho
jasmine munchell nice to meet you it's
like enchilada
nice to meet you wait so your name is
enchilada now i'm confused why would you
say like that
i'm sure like enchilada wait what the
[ __ ] is your name
hey guys felix here hey sponsor time
oh yeah you better not click away you're
browsing
internet fringe
unprotected oh double critch
yeah that was pretty cringy triple
cringe guys check out nordvpn
how many times i gotta flip and tell you
nordvpn.com
it's a great offer why a great offer you
ask
70 percent off that's a lot of
percentages
of a three-year plan you're safe for
three years gamers
not only are you safe browsing online or
when you go to online places such as
hotels and cafes
where you risk your computer information
going by and by
by hackers using a vpn helps you serve
safety
on public wi-fi that's right what it
also does is that it lets you browse the
internet from anywhere
in the world oh i can't see this video
because it's blocked
no excuse nordvpn.com i've been using
nordvpn for a long time now it's a great
service
and i do recommend it it's especially
great when you're traveling because
not only are you protected but also you
can watch the netflix
say if i want to watch japanese show i
can do it from here but while i'm in
japan
i can still watch british shows from
japan which is really nice
it's one of those things that you regret
not having until you really need it
so sign it up get the deal in your
cupboard you get an
extra month for free if you go to
nordvpn.com
pewdiepie that is to sponsor everyone
thank you for watching
and you can click on the wave from the
video now because this is the most
important part
honestly there's no point in watching
more but hey if you want to
keep watching damn you're crazy
keep watching after the ad is over and
i'm talking for no reason
damn can i drag out
see how long i can make you stay on
vacation
so how's your weekend been how have you
been good very good
so i guess like first question
i feel like he's uh he's not being
himself here it's kind of weird
i shoulde nice to meet you he's doing
that
that ceo acting or that people do oh
yeah i'm not really talking to you right
now right would you spend three hours on
the moon or three months in europe
would you spend three hours on whatever
the [ __ ] you said
would you spend three months on the moon
or one what the [ __ ] did you say
uh obviously by the way i hate this
[ __ ] question
the moon i can go ahead to europe at any
time of my god damn life
i'm not always gonna get the offer to go
to the moon am i
so i'm obviously going to the moon
they're not equal
you should phrase the question like this
if you had the choice
to go to both but which one would you
pick
first how about that god damn so stupid
three months in europe three months in
europe really i hate those questions
because you can make that reaction to
any answer
[Music]
one month in the moon really three
months in europe
really why does this bother me hey i'm
not that passionate about it by the way
just to reclaim i don't really care that
much months in europe yeah really i like
dogs
okay i'm a little bothered by it i i'm
not gonna lie it annoys me a little bit
usually dates so i'm like okay really
yeah
really that's so interesting i am a real
person
with real emotions
wow that's how this guy talks are you
from l.a or honeymoon beach area
i live kind of near usc i'm a grad
student there so
what are you interested oh that's so
interesting what are your interests
[Music]
i understand he's probably nervous and
he's just projecting this role
but he's not yeah i see through you
towards the arts
i actually sorry family for a very long
time oh okay okay
yeah so this is like totally out of my
comfort zone no i don't do this
i feel very special like thank you hold
up you had a blog when you were 12.
that's insane i love indian food yeah
no i do any any reason for that one
chief
just gonna throw this out there i love
indian food
dude if this is actually that's really
funny because that's what happened with
me and marcia the first time we chatted
she was like i'm just gonna throw this
out there i
love swedish meatballs and i was like oh
oh that's that's crazy because
cause i'm swedish wow stress of dates
you know
oh boy choose one person
right now oh he gets to pick up between
them really i feel like this is
dating life goes into the real world
right like how do you make that kind of
decision
nice to see you yet again katherine yeah
yeah i guess
she's got that lip tyler look or
whatever
good for him now you can go eat indian
food together guys i had a really great
time talking to you
i love the chance if you'd like to see
me again sometime i'd love to take you
on a date maybe like next weekend
yeah yes so is that how you get a girl
i really like to take you on a date i
had a really great time talking to you
would you like to go on a date with me i
would like to chat next weekend if
you're free
what cool i'll send you sometimes let me
get your number real quick
let me just let me just get your number
real quick here on my cell phone
here here you go
it's strange strange it's interesting
that we do this all the time and like
i've definitely done this multiple times
on my phone
but but i'm not doing in their face i
don't know i don't really see it
this it's it's really fun video wise but
it's not like an eye opener
yeah seeing it in real life being like
oh my god it's so crazy we're doing this
to people
uh this really changed my perspective on
my whole dating curtain like now
i feel like it's so different from
dating in real life or even dating
generally it
generally takes a lot longer a lot more
talk a lot more
understanding but this was like oh done
in five seconds
that's so strange so you can judge a
whole person in five seconds
just like you did it wasn't even five
seconds i saw the swipings
imagine taking an hour drive just to get
swiped left yeah
everyone simply for the girl he picked
this guy has to my family
or millionaire smile i know it
this girl does not look happy yes it's
her
[Laughter]
obviously we gotta check out the girl
version
to compare what are the differences and
now
people that prefer uh guys
let's watch this is female version
sup dudes oh god
shut up dudes sup pewds
all right let's see the crushed faces of
these guys
can guys hold it in better than girls
that's really what i'm curious about
here
you have beautiful eyes please please
swipe left pips please
oh god that's all i want that's all i
want
come on swipe left
swipe left swipe left
begin
got you [ __ ] you goddamn simp god damn
it that would have been so
funny you little weasel yeah you
weaseled yourself
in there i hope you're proud
[Music]
so sorry i want to see his reaction i
guess he's laughing
so sorry oh
my man you can't do my man like that he
looks so happy
come on hey look it's chad anything for
views will he make it
no
oh
oh ah
they break my heart i feel my of course
yeah tall man yeah you're fine
let me guess no oh wow so surprised
mr clean made it through damn all right
what the
[ __ ] is that is that is that giga chad
giga chad's step cousin what is that
joe all right respectable jawline of
course he makes it
of course with the jawline like that
god's damn
all right what do we got if you were on
a dating app
and you would swipe no please leave now
okay this is interesting because a lot
of the
girls left they didn't want to date the
guy
i'm curious how many of the guys will
say i'm gonna guess
most of the guys will stay
giga chad left of course
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait
wait something just happened and i don't
think
did it what
the guy that said you have pretty eyes
is it him
holy sh it's him why would you i am so
confu
damn it he used you
you you ah
i hate you so giga chad and
master manipulator left fair
[Music]
are you not from around here i'm not do
i do i give off that vibe
no i just i just feel a tiny accent
i am from ohio so what is there to do in
ohio nothing
no we have the rock and roll hall of
fame uh
we got you know that sounds really
boring right sorry should i say it with
a smile
it's got the rock and roll hall of fame
yeah that that's
old man wait rock and roll holland thing
that's pretty cool
that looks pretty cool i'll [ __ ] with
the rock and roll hall and fame
yeah it's a building in ohio
what can you do in ohio shatter point
a zoo these are pretty unique things for
a city a museum of
art what that's insane
funny when you found this earlier in
like kind of a half circle
um my sense of humor is a defense
mechanism did the height help you want
your kids to make varsity
yes now my kids will be athletes packer
fan patriots
oh and we're playing each other tonight
tonight
i love yeah i shouldn't have swiped um
i shouldn't swipe right god damn it um
i'm still trying to look for a church
right now since i'm like you're chopping
flying drones is what i do i break
drones and freestyle them
um yesterday i was just had a race in a
competition for nice that seems like a
great guy as a best friend
but as a date he's not going to make it
happen
i mean i kind of got catfished once but
like by a completely different person or
they just didn't look the same
she just looked nothing like her like
her pictures
yeah i don't know what kind of apps
these girls are using it's filters
they're magicians yes
it's filters they're magicians
it's messed up oh like i'm a huge like
that's awesome okay this is important
top three movies
uh network okay independence
day okay lion king okay those were three
completely
okay gotcha they're very connected
lion king it was nice to meet you
lion king independence day yeah i can
see a pattern here
mufasa dies in both ways it was really
nice to meet you
nice to meet you i don't
think so what is that bad
yeah it's bad um i think i'd really
enjoy them all as people and i
i picked them all because i do find some
part of them attractive but
i just didn't feel like that all-around
connection
that i was hoping interesting i mean
obviously
you shouldn't force yourself to date
someone if you don't want to but
she did say in the beginning didn't she
that all her dates were literally just
like meeting up
and not having a connection and now she
did the same thing with six people
and or was it eight i don't remember oh
my god you guys picked up on it your
eyes are beautiful one minute
leaves a circle what the [ __ ]
does she want to date anyone like i
don't get it
it takes time to build connection with
people don't doesn't it it'd be really
fun to see a bisexual dude
yes that'd be really interesting i love
the office is that a hobby
yeah it should be all right uh
that was really interesting i love this
video check out jubilee they got a ton
of great more videos like this thanks
for letting me react i appreciate it
thank you
it's so fun thanks for watching this
video thanks for becoming a member
107 million subscribers let's get it
see you guys next time hey dope ah
children of nine parks
it's time to raise what was once
forgotten
what creatures fart spells and poop
troops awaits hoopty is
coming to
nintendo swings
and remember it has a very big
pp pre-order promotions i mean